why being a virgin over a certain age is
a red flag to men now don't shoot the
messenger I am just I've interviewed
thousands of people on these type of
topics and over a certain age Men start
to wonder why you're still a virgin so
why at 39 it would be a red flag they
will assume one that you are lying two
that you are crazy because in their
heads it's like well why is this woman
like why did no other guy want to deal
with this women um or three you will
never be happy and no guy is ever good
enough um or you're extremely
unattractive which she actually she
wasn't an unattractive woman so it's not
that but over a certain age guys just
assume you're lying or something is that
crazy about you or you're basically
asexual